non
genre
[Musique]
éric lapointe être un million
d'allemands de vendre la carrière 14
félix et là vous revenez avec un
huitième album intitulé délivrance sur
leur voiture
des yeux sous l'eau pourquoi avoir
attendu quatre ans et nuit par sa
tournée puis de l'avoir revivre une
deuxième année est situé donc je mets ça
sur la glace pendant plusieurs années
ça donne un album dont je suis
extrêmement fier qui est assez
diversifié peut-être pas ce qui était
écrit sur une période de temps s'il ya
des chansons qui date qu'ils ont décrite
il ya 5 puis à 56 ans puis en a d'autres
qui ont été écrits il ya tout à moi
aussi je dois vous avouer que ma chanson
préférée sur cet album là c'est ma rose
du rock cru
comment faites-vous pour chanter avec
toujours autant de conviction des
paroles comme c'est dans ton on dit que
l'amour peut enfin respirer
oui
oui avec conviction parce qu'elle est
inspirante l'inspiration j'espère bien
que les gens qui inspire si
l'inspiration ou gueule travail qui
existe ici l'inspiration existe tout
soit retravaillé à ta porte
[Musique]
toujours été maladroit dans ma vie et
m'a dit et je me reprends chanson
s'éteindre de peser mes mots puis 10
mètres l'intention que je voulais donc
c'est une façon de remettre les
compteurs à zéro
une reprise de la chanson de cuban a de
l'expérience
alors pour vos enfants vous l'a chanté
cette chanson dans un rituel est que les
enfants à tous les soirs je le fais un
petit mini concert donc je le chante
tout ça de chansons j'essaie de le faire
découvrir plein de chansons on parle de
l'on passe de dessinateurs aznavour à
vigneault à brel on se promène un peu
partout élevé ce qui donne morales ayant
non une préférée qui va durer quelques
mois mais depuis deux ans c'est là la
fin du spectacle est fini ce jour tous
les soirs avec ce qui précède les labex
de du courage c'est le p'tit bonheur
essayant d'abord possible
je disais c'est toi mara
[Musique]
c'est la vie c'est si ce qui s'explique
parce que c'est une des premières
chansons que j'ai appris à guitare au
moins dans les dix premières quand
j'avais 8 9 ans ma première guitare
si une des chances des premières
chansons que j'ai chanté
vous repartez en tournée tout l'été la
scène ça vous brûle encore ah oui que
dire de plus jeudi pour la scène c'est
un métier où foot aiment avoir peur et
j'ai encore cette espèce de besoin
d'avoir pas d'avoir le trac
c'était besoin d'insécurité ce besoin de
la corde raide ce besoin de me lancer
sans fil et ses besoins
chad et cadets à la grenadine qui se
prend justement ça fait 20 ans je vous
suis sur cinq que josé ivan spectacle
cette adrénaline ou là où il avait
encore mais dans quelle mesure votre
capable de donner toute cette énergie là
pendant plus de deux ans le coût de la
vie l'adrénaline si c'est par la
connaissance de cause la drogue la plus
puissante existe et ça donne des ailes
combien l'énergie du public si l'énergie
miliciens à 100 c'est un cartel explose
f
6 / 5 juin je suis vraiment je suis
vraiment heureux je suis bien je me sens
je me sens à ma place même si des fois
j'ai peur comme un enfant dès que la
première la carie lancé je suis
constamment à lyon je m'amuse comme un
fou
si on s'habitue à ces doses à tous deux
fois par semaine tout cas quand les
autres ont tant manqué à la nuit tron
vient dépressif
puis moins deux semaines sans jouer j'ai
l'impression que ça se finit à chaque
fois j'ai besoin de remonter sur scène
pour me rassurer
on peut on ne peut s'empêcher de penser
comment vont vos vieux démons éric
lapointe les vieux démons ils vont
toujours vont toujours être présents
soit j'ai appris à composer avec ce je
veux dire avec les années la vie me fait
tellement donné tellement de signaux
d'alerté
j'apprends composer avec maintenant où
j'ai pu le faire que ça me tente lui
aussi je vieillis mais j'étais en
position pour en parler parce que
j'aime l'équipe du scav aviv mais hier
de voir sur scène cet été eric lafond
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
sow